this is the latest in a string of truck
attacks around the world the counter
extremism project reports there have
been at least 34 involving vehicles
since 2006 attacks this year in
Barcelona London and Stockholm killed at
least 29 people CBS News senior analyst
security senior security analyst Fran
Townsend was homeland security and
counterterrorism adviser to President
George W Bush he is also president of
the counter extremism project and Fran
is joining us live Fran you've covered
so many of these events right here at
the desk with us of course this hits
close to home because it took place in
our home town talk about the soft target
of bike paths in particular sure we've
gotten much better about protecting
large public areas but the difficulty in
a bike path that is the length of the
island of Manhattan it's near impossible
for authorities to really protect that
in a way that you'd hope and so people
are vulnerable when they're there you're
going to break the President of the
United States later today so the
president has the principles kameen is
meeting this morning to the this is the
national security principles they'll
then brief the president later this
morning about leads in the investment
what's the most important thing you can
tell him so the most important thing
today is going to be remember this guy
was a legal permanent resident means for
legal purposes he was a US citizen but
the program he came in on and the
president's been on a tear on Twitter
this morning frankly understandably so
because it allowed him to sponsor others
from Uzbekistan news Beca Stan has been
a hotbed of Islamic extremism there's
the Islamic movement of his news Becca
Stan it was affiliated with Isis and
this attack goes right by the ISIS
playbook right take a van or a truck
leave a note behind get out brandishing
a gun or a knife he did this by the book
and frankly it's understandable that
they're gonna look at his immigration
status and who else he could have
brought into the country there isn't it
doesn't seem like he intended to survive
either Fran no that's right look this is
we you know you call it suicide by cop
right it looks like that is but he
didn't he wasn't successful right he's
alive and that's another priority this
morning to enter but we keep hearing
it's been a reported that he is not
speaking that he's not talking right
well we'll see if that he's entitled to
a lawyer and he can invoke that right
we'll see whether or not he's what
about him by authorities you know not
much charlie while he came up
tangentially in an invest either
investigation we don't know much about
that but understand in order to target
him if you happen to walk by or get in a
cab of a terrorist and you come up
that's not enough legally to predicate
on you as a US citizen and as I say a
legal permanent resident gets all those
US citizen protections and so I don't
believe based on law enforcement sources
I'm talking to they had enough to
predicate on him thank you so much thank
you